e
all right good morning we're going to
actually get started I think we're
missing a few members hopefully they
trickle in soon um the first thing I
like to do at the beginning of every
committee is start with the Pledge of
first pledge ALG to the flag of the
United States of America to the repblic
for which it stands one
nation
all okay so um I'm excited to say this
but welcome to the first the inaugural
standing committee on housing meeting I
think it was a long time coming but I'm
glad that we're finally here and we're
um I want to welcome all the committee
uh my name is representative Joe
Alexander I represent the town of gtown
I'm serving my fourth term
um previous term I served as the
chairman of the um speaker appointed
special committee on housing where we
tackled some of these housing um crisis
um issues that are affecting the granite
state um I've said this before I'll say
it again this is the number one issue
for voters so I'm glad that we're all
here recognizing that and we can tackle
this head-on as a team and hopefully get
to some real good results so um with
that we're going to hop around a little
bit um I have a commissioner coming in
who needs to be in and out um before 11
so when he comes in I'll call on him but
throughout we're throughout orientation
I'm going to call on members to
introduce themselves and we'll go around
um so we can all get to know each other
um but so the first the first thing on
the agenda um just greetings and ground
rules so I just like to give an
opportunity for my vice chair um to
introduce
himself State representa Brian Cole for
Manchester New Hampshire uh this is my
second year up here at the state house I
was on Commerce Consumer Affairs last
term and I will be again so there's a
lot of crossover there and I'm looking
forward to working with you
all thank you Brian and um I'm going to
let my State Rep um representative
ryford I've appointed her as chair of
the committee I appointed her as clerk
so go ahead representative hi I'm
representative I'm representative Sher
reinford and I also represent Goffstown
this is my first term I am a guppy in an
ocean learning how to swim as the clerk
so I ask forgiveness first she's GNA be
great at it I know um so with that the
start time for these committees is
almost always going to be 10:00 a.m. I
don't see any reason we start before the
chairs meet at 9:00 so um we would
always start at 10: plan on Tuesdays for
our meetings um I don't see any reason
we would meet another day but if needed
I'd give you a lot of notice for that um
there's an email that you can email the
entire committee it is the house housing
committee at ledge. state. n. us um so
keep in mind please do not when you
email a committee make sure that you're
not making it a public meeting so don't
discuss um content maybe discuss meeting
times um you can just you can pass
around an amendment and say that you
plan on offering an amendment but um
this emailing the committee does not
constitute a public meeting unless you
make it one so if you email the
committee an amendment that's that's
perfectly fine but do not discuss
content over email make sure that the
committee um is all present and the
public has an opportunity to participate
with that
um dress and decorum I expect committee
members dress professionally especially
during public hearings um we need to set
an example um for the public when it
comes to testifying and uh cell phon
should not be used frequently occasional
communication is allowed but please
remain remain respectful of members of
the public and other committee members
when using your electronic devices and
um note where the fire escape is so um
with that I'm going to call on um our
committee assistant and our committee
researcher to come up real quick talk
about what their roles are um and then
there good morning everyone my name is
Jamie Wyman I am the committee assistant
for this committee as well as all of the
Committees on this side of the hallway
so I will do the scheduling I maintain
the permanent records for all of the
bills that will come to this committee
you can reach out to me if you need
anything administr L I'm a nonpartisan
employee so I'm here to help either side
of the
party and my name is Christie I'm the
committee researcher for this
committee and I um have a few other
committees as well and so I will come in
and out of the meetings and help as I
can um as nonpartisan employee I also um
can create nonpartisan research it's uh
coordinated through the chair of the
committee to benefit the committee for
examples are um legislative histories um
um compare laws from other states or
even side by-side comparison documents
of House and Senate
legislation great are there any
questions they're going to be a valuable
resource for us familiar face in here if
you have questions and you need
assistance um they're certainly here to
help so I already have chrisy on a
research project so if you think of
anything uh we can talk about that as a
committee and go from there perfect
thank you very much um so with that like
I said we're going to hop around a
little bit I see commissioner casell in
the room so commissioner can you come on
up and um commissioner Caswell from New
Hampshire Bea um I've invited him here
today to speak about housing in general
um the challenges facing the state um
and have an opportunity to answer
questions but I assume um New Hampshire
Bea will be frequent flyers in this
committee as well as they care deeply
about having a place for people to live
commissioner indeed thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for
accommodating uh a busy schedule for
today um I thought I might spend just a
few moments with everyone kind of giving
a little background on our department
and how we sort of ended up uh having a
role here in the uh Workforce housing
space in New Hampshire the Department of
Business and economic Affairs has been
around since
2017 we are the state's primary Economic
Development and promotion and
recruitment uh Department uh we have um
a number of different divisions that
include all of the state's activity to
recruit and retain businesses and
Workforce uh we work uh very directly
with all of our International Partners
to drive markets for our employers we
have staff that work on a on the ground
with businesses around the state um and
we also do uh all of the Workforce
Development funded programs Federal
funded programs um and then all of the
state tourism uh development and
marketing which um is the fun part of
the job right um back in
2022 uh when we saw the uh the state and
local fiscal recovery funds become
available under arpa then Governor snu
made a pretty significant decision which
was to invest $100 million of that
funding into the issue of affordable
housing in New Hampshire obviously we at
that time and continuing uh to this day
uh place a an extremely high um priority
on the on the crisis that we currently
have with housing in New Hampshire um it
is obviously a local and a municipal
issue but on a Statewide issue there is
no employer that I talk to around the
state of New Hampshire that says we have
enough places for our employees to live
um and uh given the fact that a big part
of what our state our state our
department does in terms of recruitment
um and we don't just recruit tourists we
recruit Workforce and we recruit
businesses uh a big part of that is the
ability to be able to find places for
those people and those businesses that
we recruit to have a place to live so uh
that is kind of why we are in this mix
uh personally uh earlier in my career I
did work for uh the Department of
Housing and Urban Development so uh I
have at least that background uh and uh
have done some private development over
the course of my career and uh I can
bring a little bit of understanding of
those markets to this initiative
so uh the $100 million was set up in a
program we called the invest NH program
that launched in the summer of
2022 uh we very quickly staffed up and
brought those funds to the market by
November of that year we had made
initial Awards of $60 million to uh
for-profit and nonprofit developers of
multifam housing in the state that had
an affordability component to it to
advance those projects quickly and
efficiently uh to Market uh we really
felt that we needed to get as many units
facilitated and available for residents
as quickly as we could that component of
the program is pretty much wrapped up at
this point we have um all told with all
the various components under invest and
AG uh had a financial relationship with
over 5,000 units uh new unit that have
come online uh we do a lot of this in
partnership with our colleagues at New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority uh
they have been doing this a lot longer
than we have and they have a number of
other really significant Federal
resources that are part of the uh
solution here but I guess one of the
things I wanted to make sure that I
emphasized is that um as we have been
through this process and I mentioned 60
million of the 100 million the remaining
40 million of that has gone to local
municipalities in the form of in three
forms first uh we had what we called our
Municipal perun program so for
municipalities that
permitted uh affordable housing uh in
their Community within a 60-day period
they became eligible for Grants of
$10,000 per unit uh to be able to use
however they felt was uh was important
so some communities put those in rainy
day funds some communities put those
funds right back into that project other
other communities used it for
infrastructure upgrades or whatever the
case might be but that was a very
popular program and and we have run the
course on that program another one uh
that worked we where we worked with
municipalities was in a demolition
program and for a lot of communities
this was actually kind of a big deal we
were able to put some resources toward
making more land available for housing
of any type uh in a community uh the
applicants were uh the municipalities
themselves um sometimes this ended up
being um just straight reduction of
density other times it was for uh Pro
projects like an Old Mill um an Old Mill
programming in uh in Franklin uh as I
recall where there were a couple of out
buildings that were no longer necessary
and we were able to make that cost a
little bit more uh available for uh the
community and for the the construction
of those units the last
program and we did this in Partnership
again with our colleagues at New
Hampshire housing was What's called the
housing opportunities program and uh
this particular program I think speaks a
lot to where we are headed uh this was a
program that allowed communities the
opportunity with some funding to
consider if we were going to do housing
of some type and at some level what does
that look like in our community um this
is not as I'm sure you are all aware a
state where this where in my view uh the
state government is going to say these
are the thresholds that every Community
must meet uh in to address this this
issue I do not I do not see that
happening and I do not personally think
that would be a good approach but where
we are able to have communities and I
call these communities the communities
of the willing to say that this is uh
important to us for one reason or
another but we're not maybe really
looking for a 500 unit multifam
development but we might be looking at
15 maybe 20 units uh in an area that
makes sense an area where there is
transportation in place where there is
infrastructure in place uh and then to
have the resources to consider how they
might actually pursue that project
either through planning or zoning or
whatever the case might be so you know
as we have gotten to the point where uh
these programs have kind of run their
course that particular program I think
we got to almost 70 communities in New
Hampshire with those funds and I think
to be able to say that there are 70
communities who effectively raised their
hand and affirmed that this is something
that they're willing to take some time
and consider really plays toward what I
think the long-term solution of this
problem begins to look like which is you
know we can have a trillion dollars in
federal money but if we don't have any
communities that are willing to sit talk
about this and to consider how they
might want to participate in the
solution to this then we we that that's
a useless amount of money right so uh
there are great examples across the
state of how this type of investment has
improved the uh the economies in those
communities without necessarily
addressing the issues of community
character and the other things that we
find so critical in New Hampshire and I
guess you know sort of the last thing I
would say is on that point we which is
when I spend most of my day and my staff
spends most of their day talking with
businesses in New Hampshire and out of
New Hampshire that are looking to come
here or are looking to expand into this
state one of the things and probably the
top of among the top two or three things
that we often hear about is how unique
New Hampshire is and how unique our
individual communities are right we are
not a state that again has these sort of
Statewide zoning rules in place that
start over time making every Community
look the same now every community in New
Hampshire feels very different and I
think all of you can certainly
appreciate that and it is something that
makes the state appealing to the very
people that we are trying to see either
come here and start a business or or
expand their business in New Hampshire
and so it connects to the housing piece
and it connects to the community
character piece and I think taking an
approach as we've taken with the invest
in ag program has um I think given a
little bit of an indication as to some
of the types of solutions that might be
available there the last thing I'll
mention Mr chairman is uh we are now um
launching uh a new program called the
housing Champions program that was uh um
was passed by the legislature a few
years ago just like three weeks ago we
announced the first 18 communities that
have been named housing Champions uh
this is uh not terribly complex process
uh where a community can apply for and
receive this designation and as a result
of that designation um there's an access
to an application process for a $5
million program for infrastructure and
uh for a municipal perun program um and
I would say for imagining that most of
you having enough familiarity with the
housing market in Hampshire that $5
million is not going to last very long
um but it is I think again an indication
of the type of structure and that we can
put in place that uh is going to have a
positive impact on the longer term
solution of the program so I hope that's
sufficient Mr chairman I'm happy to
answer and talk about any other any
other issues but I do look forward to
joining you on future occasions as well
thank you Commission I appreciate and as
somebody that helped Champion the
housing Champion program thank you for
the work that you're doing to make sure
that we um put those funds in the right
place so yes sir thank you um any
questions for commissioner Caswell
representative
Howen thank you um is there anywhere
because I I really was a big fan of the
Housing Opportunity grants I think it
was a spectacular idea is there anywhere
that we can see the uh ordinances that
communities passed that were part of the
housing Champions just so that everybody
can kind of look over and see I mean
every Community is different but you can
get some Trends out of what kind of path
and I think it would be for this
committee particularly kind of help
there there are some differences but at
the same time housing Champions has sort
of a standard set of like you have to
have certain amount you have to commit
to certain level of training for
planning board members you have to be
able to put all of the various
components in place not that we have a
ton of them but like a 79e type program
and some others if those are in place um
the standards are mostly pretty static
like that but but there might be some
areas where there's some subjectivity
involved and I think you're right that
would be a very instructive component so
let me ask my staff if we could come up
with a list of that and provide that for
the committee thank you that would be
great other questions for the
commissioner representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh Mr Caswell
did I understand correctly that um you
were able to get $60 million out to
developers by November of 2022 yeah
manam uh then I want to compliment you
on being able to do that so quickly uh I
worked for Department of Housing and
Urban Development for 29 years myself I
recognize your name although I don't we
were there at the same time I think we
were yes we were yeah um and I know how
complicated it can be to get a project
started uh and come up with all the
agreements and all get all the
stakeholders in place so I really want
to compliment you on the speed of doing
that yes well I very much appreciate
that representative and it was not an
easy process I don't know if um Andrew
Dorset who is uh our Housing Finance
director we hired him in July of 2022
and we had contracts in front of Council
in November so it was a pretty fast and
furious process um but uh one maybe that
proof that government can move at a
great other
questions well thank you commissioner I
appreciate you spending the time today
talking to us a little bit about your
department and uh I'm sure we'll see you
around soon yeah anything we can do to
assist I appreciate you starting this
committee and making sure that this
issue is really really made a priority
it's really critical I can't emphasize
that enough thank you thank
you um so with that we're going to move
into some introductions um
representative Kerwin would you like to
hello my name is Aaron Kerwin um I am
from Manchester one of the big floats um
in Manchester District 40 and this is my
first time serving what do you do for
work um I have been a state at ham for
the last 18 years and before that I was
a um social worker and a teacher well
you hi my name is Dylan Dumont I'm from
Hudson I own a property man development
company um have a long time uh uh I've
been serving a long time in Hudson on
planning board uh past two years been
zoning board uh and also um Vice
board I'm Al Holland this is my second
term I'm coming over from Municipal
County government and as I alluded to
when the commissioner was there uh
Durham put together I I represent Durham
Lee Madbury and do Ward 4 we put
together a the Town Council put together
a housing task force which we applied
for a Housing Opportunity Grant to do a
housing needs assessment and it passed a
Workforce housing overlay and the
planning board just did a student
housing definition so we've been pretty
program good morning my name is Julie
miles I represent maram Hillsboro 12 um
I will also be serving on the Commerce
Committee um uh for work I'm a medical
underwriting nurse and I have a lot of
um background in Insurance matters uh
but I'm very honored to be sitting on
this committee because it was something
that I heard a lot on the campaign Trail
as this is my first term so I'm excited
to be part of it and um see what work we
together good morning I'm George Grant
from sonina Hampshire um I've been in
the building in industry for 50 years in
residential and Light commercial own my
own company for 35 years so I think I I
think they found the right fit for me
thank you thank you good morning I'm
representative Boris I represent Ward 6
District 8 in Nashville I'm owner and
operator of a mortgage company Downtown
Nashville for the past 25 years and I
assist homeowners in acquiring
properties and issuing grants I'm very
excited to be on this committee and I do
hope to be able to work collaborate
together and assist our state with
housing I've also served on the city of
Nashville zoning board thank you thank
you represent
paig good morning
everybody I'm representative David pagee
uh really excited to be here with uh a
fabulous committee I think we're going
to get a tremendous amount done I think
there's a great will uh for action on
both sides of the aisle
uh and I hope that this is two years
where we see a lot of Forward Motion uh
I represent the town of
Conway um and when I first ran for
office it was largely motivated by what
I was seeing in the Mount Washington
Valley which was that it was becoming
harder and harder for young families to
stay and I'm very fortunate I'm raising
my kids in my family Homestead in Conway
they're the 10th Generation to grow up
in our
house um but when I talk to young people
when I go in to speak with high school
students in the
classroom um you know again and again
what I hear is they just don't see how
they'll ever be able to build a life for
themselves in the town where they grew
up and the place they love and so I'm
here to work with everyone to try to
solve that problem for my constituents
and for all of our
constituents thank you thank
you hello everyone my name is Michael
Aaron I represent Sullivan County
District District 8 which is made up of
nine
municipalities aworth Claremont Cen Goan
langon lster Springfield sunnye and
Washington representative Grant and
I represent sunap and Springfield
together I am the chair of the aworth
planning board and I've been on the
planning board since 2014 I'm also on
the uh School District budget Committee
in my community I live in aworth
which no one knows where it is and we
like it that way I hope to work well
you hi my name is Calvin bullier um I'm
very honored to be here and be on this
committee um with all of you um I'm the
father of three kids I live in Littleton
New Hampshire and I am one of the
representatives um from Grafton 1 which
includes um a handful of towns in
northern Grafton County um part of my
background I am an attorney um I am also
a New Hampshire real estate broker um
and I also serve on the Littleton
planning
board morning my name is Matt Hicks I
represent conquer W 10 so marily and I
compete for the shortest commute I think
on this committee uh which is March 24 I
came over from mun Municipal County
government with Al um where I think both
of us were very much focused on the
housing issue so I'm happy to be here
here I'm an educator I run a school here
in uh conquer I also uh been on the
planning board for decade and a half and
I'm on the board of directors of the
local Chamber of Commerce so I see this
issue from all sides so thank
you good morning uh I'm merold Gibbs I
represent conquered ward nine and this
is my second term in the legisl
legislature um before I retired I worked
as I said for 29 years for the US
Department of Housing and Urban
Development um so I'm very familiar both
with how federal grants work and also
with the complexity of setting up um uh
Housing Development uh I actually worked
for the office of fair housing and equal
opportunity but what my unit dealt with
was uh fair housing requirements Equal
Opportunity requirements for HUD
programs so I worked with all types of
Hud programs including many housing
programs and prior to going to HUD I was
director of the New Hampshire Human
Rights
Commission thank you
representative I'm representative Sher
Miner from
lonia I am a property owner not manager
no longer I stepped out of the business
but we own some mobile home parks and
rental property I have run an an
association that actually helps
landlords and tenants alike um when
they've kind of had no one to turn to um
Corrections my name is s Clon I
represent the towns of Troy and Fitz
William which is chesher
12 uh that's the greater Keen
metropolitan area if you're not familiar
with cheser County and for the last 45
years I have worked in housing industry
I have worked for Major Market Builders
like warehouser and us home corporation
and major markets 35 years ago I moved
to New Hampshire to raise my family and
in New Hampshire I have been a and am a
licensed real estate
broker uh in New Hampshire Vermont
Massachusetts I employ other people as
salespeople and have for 20 30 years I
manage properties for other people as
well as redeveloping
properties that I own and managing
people represent Reed would you like to
introduce yourself
sure uh Ellen Reed representing new
fields and New Market Rockingham 10 this
is my fifth term I've made housing and
dealing with the housing crisis my
number one issue for the last several
years sponsoring 11 housing bills from a
variety of different um aspects and
approaches uh last term alone and um in
my opinion it's the most important thing
we need to solve in this state and it
and IT addresses multiple other crises
that we have in the state but if if we
solve housing then we will solve or at
least make strides to S towards solving
these other
issues thank you well welcome um so the
charge pursuant to house rule 31 is the
duty of the committee on housing to
consider subjects related to housing
Condominiums landlord tenants rights um
residential zoning planning and other
matters that may be referred to it
there's 10 Republicans eight Democrats
on this committee and I've assign
seatings with the collaborative goal in
mind so you shouldn't be sitting next to
all Democrats or all Republicans so
hopefully we get to know each other um
occasionally we'll be assigned bills
that come from other committees um but
if that's the case it's mainly our job
to consider those specific subject areas
that we have voted in as um um
persistent to housing policy um and
occasionally we may may decide to set up
subcommittees on a bill so um I've
scheduled some public hearings for next
Tuesday um if it any time the committee
feels that we may need to spend some
time working on it further um please
state that during the public or after
the public hearing um we'll have an
opportunity to talk about that set up a
subcommittee maybe some um members can
um I ask that you ask all questions
during a public hearing through the
chairman so um for example when
commissioner Caswell was here we did a
great job with that um I won't tolerate
debates with Witnesses and unfair
questions our job is to ask questions
evaluate the merits of a bill I'll try
to be as Fair as possible to all members
but I will not tolerate disrespect to
Witnesses or other committee members the
public hearing is also not a time to
make a speech please save comments for
our executive session again I will not
tolerate unfair treatment to the public
if you're sponsor and you are a member
of the committee you may do one of two
things one you can choose to ask fair
questions to Witnesses or two you may
testify if you testify you can return to
your committee seat but you must remain
silent for the entirety of the hearing
in cases which I'm the prime sponsor on
a bill which there are a few that have
been referred to this committee I'll
defer to the my vice chair to run the
public hearing on that bill um
to make sure it's fair hearing we may
take actions action on bills during a
public hearing day and pursuant to house
rules that's the discretion of the
chairman well I have no intention of
conducting executive session unless our
committee is full um or with
consultation with our ranking member
representative page um I do have the
right as chairman to call an executive
session at any time um during before or
after a notice public hearing and if you
have questions about the ethics of
recusing yourself from a bill or a
hearing um Richard Lambert and
legislative Services can help you um
with those ethics questions
um with the executive session there's no
public input during an executive session
without my consent if you'd like to
draft an amendment on the bill you can
do so through the portal um similar to
where you sponsored legislation or
co-sponsored them um if you need
additional Help contact your ranking
member the chairman of the committee um
in the first year there are four motions
that can be made ought to pass ought to
pass with amendment in expedient to
legislate or retain a retain motion
allows the committee the opportunity to
hold on to the bill over the summer um
and work on as a full committee or
subcommittee all Amendment votes and
final votes on the bills will be done
via roll call um from the clerk of the
committee immediately following
executive session if you made the motion
on a bill or if you're in the minority
and disagree would like to debate on the
floor please write the committee report
and send directly to me um pursuant to
house rules for approval um I will then
send it to committee assistant to get
into the house calendar the committee
report should outline the majority and
minority position on the bill any
possible amendments and what they do and
the recommendation it's critical we have
a full committee during exec sessions so
if you cannot be here when a scheduled
executive session is happening please
contact your partisan office and they
will find a replacement for us um to
conduct that so with that I have a
couple more are there any questions I'm
just like throwing some information at
you there's uh quite a bit of um
freshman on the committee so I just want
to make sure I outline some ground rules
before we move forward representative
Reed thank you Mr chair uh just not so
much questions uh just clarification on
a couple things the rule about you can
only uh act on one side of the table is
true of everyone regardless of whether
or not you've co-sponsored a bill so you
had said specifically if you've
sponsored but it's true of anybody yes
you can either testify whether you've
co-sponsored or not or question and the
second piece is it is my understanding
of best practice that when you submit a
a report minority majority or otherwise
that that actually goes to both the
committee assistant and the chair yes
and the committee assistant will not
publish it without approval of the
chairman um I won't edit substit edit um
committee reports but if there are
inaccuracies in it I may ask for a
redraft or to make changes to it
representative
Paige I think most of what you just
covered most most of us here in my
caucus are aware of but for our newer
members if those notes are something you
be willing to share that would be a
great shortcut for us and just
especially because one of our
Representatives is absent today who is a
freshman um just to make sure everybody
is has the same information up front I
appreciate that sounds great of course
any other
questions okay um so I have asked a few
people to um present on housing so um I
have asked uh Chris schiler from
Elmgrove to um give a brief presentation
on the housing crisis and what he's
dealing with as a developer so come on
up
Chris good morning how we all doing yes
please good morning all right thank you
for having me here I appreciate the
opportunity um over the last several
years I've been involved in in
testifying like this I've been on the
governor sununu's um housing stability
Council um uh Hampshire homebuilders
Association Apartment Association of New
Hampshire and most recently Manchester's
uh lead paint commission so um along
with doing the work of building housing
and managing housing I've I've really
gotten to know the legislative process
pretty well really happy to be asked to
come and share my perspective on the
current situation with the housing
market I didn't have a lot of time to
prepare and I want to make sure I
covered everything so I've written some
things down
um I guess I would say the hous Market
in New Hampshire is in crisis mode today
and has been for several years single
family home prices continue to rise the
median home price in New Hampshire right
now is
$520,000 that's double the national
average uh there are currently two
months of housing stock available on the
market when a six months of housing
stock is considered
healthy rental rates have
increased 30% over the last few years in
2019 the median rent for a two bedroom
apartment in New Hampshire was $1,400 a
month today it's $1850 and when I spoke
for uh representative Cole's uh group
six months ago it was
1,700 um I will say that either whether
it be because of the winter months or um
New Stock coming into the market we're
seeing prices um
stabilize drop a little bit there are
some some concessions we see out there
in the market right now but I wouldn't
count on that to indicate that that
we're at the end of um our crisis for
rents to go up from $1,400 to
$1,850 in such a short period of time is
is dramatic and if you think about it
with affordable housing those rents are
prescribed the average rent of an
affordable unit through the litec the
low-income housing tax credit program
right now is about $1,500 $1600 a month
that's 100 or $200 more than what a
market rate apartment costs in
2019 um it's dramatic I've been doing
this for over 20 years I've I've
experienced plenty of down markets over
that time 2008 um always offering
concessions very competitive markets
I've never experienced it the way it is
now um which is the polar opposite of
that vacancy rates are reported to be as
low as 6% when a healthy Market is
5% um our portfolio sits around 2% and
really the only reason for that I think
is because of the time it takes for us
to turn Apartments it's also our housing
challenges are are affecting unemploy
are affecting employment they're
affecting the trades getting people from
the trades to come to New Hampshire and
be able to afford to live here and then
do the work that needs to be done to
construct and maintain housing um is
another side challenge of of our housing
troubles where people should be paying
30 35% of their income towards housing
today the most recent data I saw they're
paying as much as 58% of their income
toward housing it's that's
unsustainable um and if you look at our
senior
population where there's very little
room for income growth all they're doing
is getting rent increases they're not
getting there's no additional income
coming in so it's especially challenging
for our older um res
I'm seeing similar Trends in my
portfolio as I mentioned uh we have a 2%
vacancy
rate our average rent is 4 is
$1,873 a month and to give you a
perspective of what the supply and
demand situation is we have about 35
vacant apartments at any given time we
we currently own and manage over 1500
Apartments throughout New Hampshire
um of that about a third is low-income
housing affordable housing um so even
though a large portion of our of our
portfolio is is Affordable our rents are
still right there at the median for the
state in any given month we'll receive
450 inquiries for an apartment that's up
one month 450 inquiries that's 6,000 or
so inquiries a year for 35 apartments so
we we have no problem renting apartments
we have a have challenges getting them
rent ready but other than that we have
far more people looking for apartments
than we can possibly serve homelessness
Is On The Rise um and I hope people in
the room understand that there's a
direct correlation between homelessness
and housing availability it doesn't
really matter what type of housing we
build if we build enough housing to
create a a healthy housing market
homelessness will will
drop right now viously homelessness Is
On The Rise um the latest numbers show a
58% increase in in homelessness over the
last uh well I should say yesterday's
meeting with the housing stability
Council was looking at 2023 data they
don't have good 2024 data but the the
rise in homelessness is is is dramatic
and it's I think number one or number
four in the entire country number one in
the whole whole
country it's a
problem in order to have a healthy
housing market we need 30,000 units
today right and over the next 10 years
the numbers are 990,000 units we don't
need to talk about the 90,000 units how
are we going to get 30,000 units my
company has brought 500 units to Market
in the last two years we if we brought a
thousand units to Market in a year we
would think that we had done a fantastic
job and been very successful we need 30
more people or 30 more development
developers to do the same
thing so my perspective and based on my
my time with the housing stability
council is the issues that cause this
right in migration I'm not talking about
illegal migration I'm talking about
people moving from Massachusetts and
other states to come to New Hampshire
because this is a great state with low
taxes great quality of life people are
moving here because it's less expensive
for them to live here in tra and travel
to Massachusetts for example for their
for their jobs that alone is is creating
tremendous amount of competition in the
market and driving up prices they're
able and willing to pay more in Boston
you can rent an apartment for $4,000 a
month and it's a good deal you can come
here and rent the same apartment for
$2,000 a month and although it's
expensive to us native New Hampshire
folks it's it's a bargain for them it's
driving up
prices it's good for our state too
though to have 30 ,000 people over the
last two years move into our state who
are well-educated
um family you know people that want to
raise a family in our community but we
don't have the housing for it inflation
over the past few years has dramatically
increased costs of owning and caring for
Real Estate we've seen increases in in
costs of 30% give or take taxes
utilities Insurance labor and materials
across the board and what a lot of
people don't realize is that there's a
lot of people that have owned real
estate multif family housing in the
state for many many years and they're
now in a market where selling today is
in their best interest and they're also
maybe at the end of their career and
they're looking to retire out of it so a
lot of real estate is being transferred
to new owners including ourselves who
are putting a lot of debt on these
properties that's driving up rents as
well I think that's unavoidable but it's
a reality of the situation um costs for
construction have risen along with
inflation interest rates are at
approximately 6 and a half% right
now so our expenses are are going up
whether we're constructing new housing
or just maintaining the existing housing
we have zoning restrictive I'm sorry
zoning and restrictive local and state
regulations have not adapted to this
need at all and there's still a great
deal of resistance to to change in that
area many communities in the state are
uninterested in approving new housing
developments over concerns about
mythological issues like Parking School
enrollment infrastructure and crime um
the nimbyism is especially strong when
it relates to affordable housing now
affordable housing is housing built for
people that earn between 60 and 80% of
area median income affordable housing
can be built for people that make 20 30
40 50 um% Area immediate income as well
but generally defined as between 60 and
80% that is for a household in New
Hampshire that earns around 50 5 to
$75,000 a year that's not low income um
it's hardly low income but the hardest
hit populations are for folks especially
families that are earning $50,000 a year
or less there's no housing at all for
that for that segment of the market and
it's a huge segment of the market um
housing Choice vouchers are probably the
um only solution for for people that are
making below $30,000 a year and there's
a lot of real estate owners who um
choose not to accept those vouchers um
for their own reasons it's a challenging
um administratively burdensome
um contract to deal with um but they're
doing a good job of recognizing that
they need to be a partner to landlords
and offering some incentives but also
just making the the partnership with
with property owners um a little bit
more uh two-way and uh I think that's
going a long way toward getting more
Property Owners to accept those vouchers
but again somebody has to pay for those
vouchers and uh you know as far as I I
know we have as many vouchers as we can
afford in the state and um I don't know
how they'd fund more the solution to
building more housing especially
affordable
housing is is this uh new zoning
ordinances allow for shorter setbacks
more density more height and fewer
single family only zones light density
zoning would allow for four units on
single family lots um adus by right and
fewer parking restrictions there's a lot
of C cities throughout the country that
have adopted light density and it's not
as shocking um when it actually goes
into practice as as as I think a lot of
people that live in communities think it
would be
um Europe is almost entirely light
density
zoning State subsidy if you do anything
this year fund
fund money to New Hampshire housing to
put directly into the building and
subsidy of of the building of affordable
housing through the low-income housing
tax credit program streamlining the
permitting process is is is key you know
in a healthy Market nobody cares how
long it takes for a developer to get a
project um permitted but it the
permitting process as it stands is
unpredictable it takes a lot of time
time is money and there's not a lot
of certainty around whether or not a
project will will get approved from the
beginning so often times a viable
project will will will just not be
developed out of
uncertainty um and we need to educate
our local planning and zoning boards on
the reality of the housing situation and
help them overcome the myths about
housing that fuel nimbyism in in our
communities so New Hampshire Home
Builders the housing stability Council
are two groups that I'm involved with um
that have been talking about this issue
for years I think they're excellent
resources for anyone who wants to
understand more about exactly what's
going on in the housing market here and
I recommend that that you reach out to
members of those groups and and talk to
them especially with home builders on
the on the development side on the
construction side they they have a
really good handle on what is needed in
order to um reduce the costs of
Development and Construction and get
more housing built
that is my testimony thank
you thank you very much for your uh
experiences questions go ahead
representative Hicks thank you Mr chair
um you mentioned a lot and I thank you
for your expertise one thing I don't
think I heard was short-term rentals or
second homes um in New Hampshire and if
that is contributing to this problem um
could you comment on that
briefly so I was at a I saw a speak a
speaker recently ly talk about that and
he couldn't correlate that there that
short-term rentals is is causing more
issues but I can't imagine that up in
the North Country it it doesn't um but I
don't know for a fact I I don't know
that that's an issue that that is the
lowest hanging fruit that we need to
deal
with but I would look if I was in the
North Country I'd look at it more
closely um because obviously there's a
limited amount of housing up there and
and if some of it's set aside for
short-term rentals
that's going to take away from folks
that work up there I don't know if those
homes that are being Airbnb up there are
in are affordable to people um working
normal typical jobs in the North Country
either so I guess that might be one
reason why it it isn't leading aiding in
the problem um but it certainly has had
an effect I mean Airbnb has has blown up
over the my sister owns five of them she
would say it's not a problem but I don't
know represent kwin thank you chair um
you mentioned that there was two
organizations to look into but I didn't
catch what they were oh my uh well on
the construction side the New Hampshire
Home Builders has a really excellent
government Affairs committee um and they
seem to have their heads wrapped around
a lot of the solutions and are are
really working with the legislature this
year to try to get some of those um in
the Forefront so they're a great
resource Matt Mayberry um and then the
housing stability Council which is
Governor sununu's Council um we meet
monthly we have have breakoff groups
um there's a lot of data available
through that through that group there's
50 members so lots of conversations I gu
I guess the point I want to make about
those two organizations is um they have
different purposes but I have noticed
that it doesn't matter what side of the
aisle you're on in with with this issue
for the most part everybody tends to
agree on what what the Sol what the
solutions are and and really what the
problems are what they stem from I think
that's really help and uncommon too
so thank you other questions um
something that I want to focus on or
have this committee really dive into is
a lot of the permitting reforms
specifically state level permitting um
in the perfect world have stability on
when you want to start a permitting
project and have a a set end date um so
I have my the committee researcher
looking into each department and what
they require where in the RSA it's
required and um or if it's in rules
where it's required and I guess I'd love
your feedback on where because if we're
going to ask maybe towns to do something
and streamline their projects the state
also needs to lead on this and so if
there's if there's problems on the state
level where you're finding that things
are taking too long or
um uh there's more red tape than that's
needed we would love that sort of
feedback me specifically um because I
see that as a charge of this committee
as well is to make sure that our
departments are running as smoothly and
efficiently as possible sure sure so for
me and my expertise I've been I'm on the
property management side of our business
and I have been for for 20 years um I
have never pulled a permit for anything
however um my understanding is that it's
the uncertainty about the time the
permanent process will take and if there
was a 60-day turnaround and let's say
after that 60 days often times you could
get a denial or you could get a list of
things that need to be addressed before
a permit would be approved and then
another 60-day period um extends right
so now your 60 turns into 120 I think
what we'd be looking for is that we have
60 days for a permit to be approved and
then we get back a list and we have 10
days to turn that around rather than
extending another 60 days and then
finding out at the end of that that
things would be um that or or delayed
even further it really there's a
carrying cost to to owning um land or or
a piece of real estate that you want to
develop and you're paying for that every
single month regardless of whether or
not a permit's been been approved and
it's that uncertainty that creates um
trouble I think for developers John
Stevens is putting together a forum that
we were invited to participate in on um
on the permitting process and and
working looking to find out ways to
streamline that so so um I hope
something comes out of that I don't know
what it will be but uh we'll have some
folks there at that at that Forum that
um do this on a reg on a regular
basis well you'll be happy to know that
I'm coordinating with John Steven on
that Forum so wonderful then you can
tell us that goes after there was you
know there's another piece too that um I
was speaking with
uh John about and that that has to do
with um inspections so the state has uh
a process where they they will inspect
um whether it be Wetlands or or or
whatever um and there aren't a lot of
inspectors at the local level or at the
state level they're spread very very
thin it's like elevator inspectors I
think there's two in the entire State of
New Hampshire um the idea to somehow
allow developers to hire certified
Professional Engineers inspectors um in
their field to to go in for a fee and
and and do that work could save a lot of
time um and clear up a lot of backlog in
the inspection process um while giving
the developer an opportunity to either
you know go with the state inspector at
no cost or pay a cost to get something
done more quickly um I'm not off the top
of my head sure who is um proposing that
legislation this year but I think we
will see something like that and uh it's
it's it's actually a pretty smart idea I
think it it could work out really well I
believe Senator Murphy has a bill in to
deal that um CU he brought it up to me
um it's it's based off of a Florida
model where you could for a fee hire
somebody to to cover the inspection if
they're certified through the state or
something like that and I think it's an
interesting idea the state would have to
agree that they're qualified to do that
obviously um but it's a great idea I
think other
questions all right seeing none thank
you thank you apprciate
it okay so I'm we're running a bit ahead
of schedule I had originally asked for
Rob dais from New Hampshire housing to
come but I don't see him in the room
right now
so
um I'm not sure maybe take a quick break
maybe like 10 15 minutes and then we'll
just
e
okay we are coming back our guest is
here is everyone back good okay so um
the funniest thing happened earlier is
representative hegner was sitting in the
audience and did not know to come grab
her chair um as a seated State Rep so at
this time I want to call on
representative hegner to uh introduce
yourself and welcome to the
committee hello hello I'm Karen hegner
and I'm from
Manchester and um this is my first year
and I am in title insurance and have
been for over 23 years um so I'm very
excited to be part of this housing
committee and get to meet everyone and
let's get some things done thank you
awesome well welcome um these are
assigned seats so feel free to grab that
seat at any
time anytime you wish um so with that I
want to welcome um two uh members from
New Hampshire Housing Finance Rob dpis
who's the executive director and Jack
rman who I don't know your exact role
but um is part of Housing Finance so um
they're they're here to give us some
information about um what they do and a
welcome you mind just turning on your
mic cut thank you okay uh well thank you
so much for having us it's nice to be
here and I uh I guess I apologize for
being what feels like uh late but I'll
you know I guess in the military and
theater they say like 10 minutes early
is on time and um so here we are uh as
the chairman said uh I'm Rob dais I'm
the executive director of New Hampshire
Housing and title I can't remember but
Jack and I work closely together on
legislative affairs to help share
information with you and answer whatever
questions you may have so we'll spend 10
or 15 minutes talking about who we are
and what we do um and be happy to take
any questions after that uh before I
start I just want to say thank you for
your service to the state and for your
uh work and Leadership on on this
important issue um we have some handouts
going around and so hopefully those will
make the rounds and if there's extras um
maybe we can share them with folks in
the audience but that's uh three
documents first just our most recent
annual report and that might be useful
to refer to while I'm talking uh then an
a fact sheet on the affordable housing
fund which is one of the resources at
the state level that we are the stewards
of and then uh information sheet uh that
came out of a recent uh research project
that we did with respect to the number
of school children that are enrolled in
local public schools when new housing is
built um so uh without further Ado I'll
I'll tell you who we are and and New
Hampshire housing maybe it's uh helpful
to First say what we are not we're not a
state agency we're not part of state
government uh and we're often confused
for a state agency which is
understandable because we run a lot of
programs that sort of look uh
governmental and are in their nature but
uh we were established about 40 years
ago by state law uh as an independent
self-supporting Corporation we have a
mission to promote finance and support
Housing Solutions uh for the people of
New Hampshire and when we were created
as an independent entity it was sort of
part of a national Trend uh that was uh
where States created these independent
bodies to take advantage of new federal
tax provisions and issue mortgages that
helped encourage home ownership for
first time and moderate income home
buyers and basically the states didn't
want all that debt on their books and so
that's kind of you know the inelegant
origin story but I think for a number of
reasons uh that we can get into it's
worked out pretty well and that over the
years as either new programs have
emerged on the federal level or the
state has had you know housing work that
needs to be done they've turned to us
and asked us to do that and and and
we've been able to help uh perhaps at
times in ways that uh you know
demonstrated more agility or uh
flexibility than we might have been able
to um to employ uh had we been a state
agency uh we are organized into three
operational divisions and at this time
if you want to you can pull uh pull out
your annual report there um so I'll tell
you quickly what they are and what they
and and what they each do uh the first
in our guide is multif family housing
and this is probably of the most visible
aspect of our work
um it's where I worked so I've been at
New Hampshire housing for 10 years
before that I worked for North Branch
construction here in conquer uh so I was
sort of building homes and I switch
sides of the table uh but still work
closely with Builders uh developers both
for-profit and nonprofit all over the
state to uh help create and preserve
affordable homes for the people of New
Hampshire and um a lot of people have a
lot of different ideas and in some cases
stigma associated with what affordable
housing is and looks like and a lot of
that comes from sort of the legacy of
public housing which hasn't been built
in this country in many decades and uh
there's a lot of complicated reasons
that we don't need to get into about why
public housing has sort of uh an
unfortunate Legacy in ter in people's
minds and understanding of what that
housing is and means um but the housing
that we're financing now and that we're
helping uh independent developers and
Builders to create has very little in
common with that housing uh essentially
what this uh housing uh properties like
the ones that you see in these pages
uh the way they come together is that
developers compete and we allocate below
Market Capital whether that's through
tax credits or a affable housing fund
debt or tax exempt uh debt which is
funded by Bond buyers on the private and
public markets um they accept that below
Market capital in exchange for a uh
binding commitment to rent those new
apartments that they're creating to
people who are uh not rich low or
moderate income for rents that they can
afford they also commit to accepting
housing Choice vouchers AKA Section 8
vouchers if that's how uh the resident
is paying their rent and uh if you've
never been to a uh affordable property
that's been financed in the last say
decade I highly encourage you to get
there reach out to us and we'll be happy
to coordinate but these are um you know
they're not fancy but they're beautiful
places that I think any one of us could
be proud to call home that people are
proud to call their homes um and that's
not what everybody sort of thinks of
when you think about uh affordable or
public housing in the past um there's a
lot of numbers a lot pictures you can
take your time with it and reach out
with questions if you'd like I will just
mention one other aspect of it which is
we do a fair amount of uh work on
Supportive Housing so housing for people
who need uh Supportive Services to
maintain their housing and stability and
improve their lives whether that's folks
with uh substance substance use
disorders mental illness developmental
disabilities people who have experienced
homelessness um veterans uh in in some
cases and so on um and and many some of
those do care
you know a deep rent subsidy uh so it's
not just you know a rent that would be
affordable to somebody at 80% of area
median income or something like that um
and most recently we've agreed at the
state's request or at the request of the
opioid commission chaired by Senator
Rosenwald to uh administer an opioid use
disorder uh funding program so we're we
just issued a notice of funding
opportunity for creators of recovery and
Supportive Housing for folks with that
particular um who struggle with that
condition uh uh and and are looking
forward to working with again uh
developers and Recovery housing
providers across the state uh to to get
that money which came from the
settlements from like the pharmacies and
drug companies uh out out to help the
people who that crisis has
affected I will keep moving in the
interest of time I before I do the
affordable housing fact sheet that you
have I'm not going to get into all the
details of the affordable housing fund
there's legislation introduced and
obviously there will be a conversation
as part of the budget about whether
uh that uh you know additional funding
is in order for the affordable housing
fund but that's a state level trust fund
that we administer on behalf of the
State uh right now the first $5 million
in real estate transfer tax money goes
to the affordable housing trust fund we
essentially uh the federal programs that
do the bulk of the work in terms of
financing new or preserved affordable
housing are uh designed to not fund the
whole thing so you have to get private
debt you have to get State money um the
affordable housing fund allows us to to
uh fully utilize uh at at best uh fully
utilize um or at least leave Less on the
table in terms of tax exempt Bond
financing and uh low-income housing tax
credit that the uh federal government
allocates to us on a sort of per capita
allocation and that's part of the
permanent federal tax
code I'll move on to home ownership uh
home ownership is sort of again like how
we began and I like to mention that this
is how when my family moved to New
Hampshire 13 14 years ago uh we bought
our first home with a New Hampshire
housing uh VA loan long before I knew uh
anything else about New Hampshire
housing uh we're not a retail lender so
you can't come to New Hampshire Housing
and get a loan we're essentially a
wholesale lender so we compete with like
big National firms like rocket mortgage
and United Wholesale Mortgage that are
uh uh and and we provide opportunities
for local lenders whether that's uh
Banks like Meredith Village or Marat
County uh walpool Savings Bank or
mortgage companies like Pinnacle
Mortgage uh to offer products to their
clients uh that particularly for
first-time home buyers I mean they're
they're generally limited to first-time
home buyers and people who uh meet
income uh requirements but because
they're financed with tax exempt bonds
um you know people buy those Bonds on
the or investors buy those Bonds on the
public market and pay a premium because
their their Dividends are tax exempt
that makes the debt a little bit cheaper
and so uh you know we're generally uh
one percentage Point 100 basis points
lower than what the market is it varies
a lot depending on the specific program
and what you're putting down uh you know
a lot of these are FHA or low down
payment loans but not all of them so it
just allows people to achieve home
ownership um in in what is really a very
very competitive market as I'm sure
you've all heard and are probably
Hearing in other presentations there's
very limited inventory and home prices
have um have gone crazy in the last
couple years frankly um we also
uh so I mentioned uh I don't know if I
mentioned down payment assistance is a
component of these loans and that's not
uh you know State money it's it's uh
essentially The Profit that we make by
issuing these bonds we put back into the
bond indentures and offer down payment
assistance of5 10 or
$15,000 so that because we so often see
renters who are paying you know $2,000
$2500 a month in rent in some markets uh
but and and it's not no mystery about
why they can't save for a down payment
and so uh down payment assistance which
goes in as a uh a soft second
essentially it's a uh loan that is only
repayable upon sale or refinance of that
mortgage um and we have precautions to
make sure people don't get underwater
and get hurt um but but that helps a lot
of people achieve home ownership as well
I'll move on to assisted housing the
assisted housing division uh essentially
serves as the public housing authority
for areas of the state that don't have a
local public housing authority that
means we administer the housing Choice
voucher a Section 8 program which is
entirely federally funded through the
HUD budget um so there's 17 phas
actually you might a lot of people don't
realize but of course Manchester you
know conquered Nashua do Portsmouth have
their own uh PHA but also some smaller
communities um like summersworth and uh
Berlin and others um there's about 10 or
12,000 vouchers in the state and we
administer uh roughly third of them uh
you know I think the important thing to
understand about this it serves uh if
you look at sort of the incomes and
demographics of the families that we
serve with these various programs this
is by far the lowest income and most
vulnerable the median income of the
folks that we help it's not I thought it
was in our oh yeah there it is
9,260 largely people on fixed income uh
78% are seniors or people with a
disability many of them both uh this
program has historically been a really
important tool to help people who are at
a difficult time in their lives who may
be experiencing housing instability or
homelessness um I think the important
thing for all of us to understand is
that because uh rents have increased a
lot and we're paying that rent on behalf
of the voucher holders uh their income
has not increased very much as I said
most of them are on a fixed income uh
the budget has increased a little bit
but um but not a whole lot and so used
to be we had a waiting list of maybe
four or 5,000 people and you could uh
reasonably expect that if you signed up
and were eligible you might might get a
voucher in four or five years which is
hard that's a hard message to deliver
but um you know you can maybe see that
in the Horizon at this point um we have
a waiting list that's ballooned to 7,000
and uh for those who sign up with you
know just sort of like regular eligible
people even if they're experiencing
homelessness but they're not they don't
have a preference because they're you
know referred by DHHS and avoiding
nursing home care or terminally ill is
another one you know there's a few
preferences that will get you a voucher
in a year or something but apart from
that it's um you know it might be 8
years and it might be never because of
the other folks who are coming onto the
um onto the pro program with I guess
what's categorized as more urgent needs
and so we just need to be realistic
about the ability of that Federal
program to sort of serve as a stop Gap
and prevent homelessness in the
state um that's our three operational
divisions there is a fourth uh team
which is small and mighty and does a lot
of important work that may be also
visible to you and Jack is actually a
member of that team so I'm going to turn
over him to talk a bit about uh
engagement policy and
Communications super thanks Rob uh and
good day everybody it's sort of in
between good morning and good afternoon
my name is Jack rudderman and I serve as
New Hampshire housing's energy and
legislative affairs advisor which means
I'll be spending a lot of time in this
building and in this room uh this coming
legislative
session I want to tell you just a little
bit about our engagement policy and
Communications Group and and what we do
um we produce research on key housing
issues um like a school enrollment study
that was recently completed uh assessing
the impact of housing on School
enrollment uh and then uh on local tax
rates uh we published a municipal guide
to RSA 79e which is the community re
revitalization tax relief
incentive um the state housing needs
assessment uh and also the annual
residential rental cost survey which
tells us what housing costs are for
renters and home buyers across the NES
across the state so it really gives
gives policy makers and the public um uh
and other stakeholders uh a detailed
portrait of the housing market um and it
it does it you know by each County
throughout the state and you see a fair
amount of variability but um if you're
reading in the paper um that the vacancy
rate is
x% uh or median rents for a two-bedroom
apartment has gone up by 38% usually the
source of that is is this survey which
is done
annually we also serve as a resource for
towns and cities that are seeking local
solutions to the housing crisis so we
work closely with several Regional
Workforce housing coalitions around
around the state and we also manag the
state's Housing Opportunity planning
grants program or the The Hop grants as
some of you may have heard um and that
program uh has provided funding to more
than 60 communities um they've received
grant funding uh which came to us by way
of uh invest New Hampshire uh Governor
shu's initiative um on the housing front
um and what the communities do with
these funds is they first conduct a
housing needs assessment to figure out
what are the needs within our own
particular Community um and then they
look at their zoning ordinances and and
all local land use
ordinances um to explore ways to remove
barriers to increasing the supply of
housing at the local level so um that
program really um has grown very quickly
uh and a lot of work is being carried
out um uh at the local level um and this
is a a program um that we feel is is
having an impact and will continue to
have a a significant impact uh over the
course of the next few years so that's
just a a quick look um at the work we do
in the um EPC division uh and with that
I'm going to turn it back to
Rob and that pretty much covers it in
terms of who we are and what we do I you
know intentionally haven't talked about
the housing market I think you're
getting other presentations on that but
that's another area where we're happy to
be a resource because we have all these
Partners in different uh sort of corners
of the housing uh industry and and
Market uh I think we can help to sort of
make sure that you're making the best
informed decisions you can but with that
we would be very happy to take any
questions or entertain discussion well
thank you rob thank you Jack um are
no
questions all right thank you very much
today um so with that that's all I have
for orientation um laying out some
ground rules um listening to a couple
speakers uh on the agenda moving forward
next Tuesday we're starting public
hearings I scheduled I believe eight um
there's originally six I added two more
hopefully quick ones at the in the
afternoon um goal is to usually be out
of here around 4: um so so with that um
does anybody have anything from the
committee that they'd like to contribute
break yes okay so um I believe the
Republicans are going to go have lunch
together so um sorry we hopefully
we'll um so just aind the Republicans
where are you eating though Democrats
will be meeting somewhere else as well
oh you're not going to tell us where
you're meeting it's uh undisclosed
location representative paig do you have
anything good I'm good I think I think
my team knows we're up we're in uh room
403 and let's in case anybody needs to
go grab lunch somewhere let's meet there
in half an hour the Democrats are more
frugal great well everyone have a great